anxious sometimes it's challenging and
overwhelmed i've seen him go through
a lot kanye west visited a hospital near
his ranch in wyoming on saturday
a source tells e.t that the 43-year-old
rapper
who was reportedly only at the hospital
for about 10 minutes
had anxiety from all the support and
visitors he's received
in the past weeks yay's team and friends
like dave chappelle
justin bieber and damon dash flew out to
check on him
real friends how many of us how many
of us how many jealous real friends
according to the source when kanye got
to the hospital he decided he would
rather be seen at the ranch
when the ambulance arrived to his ranch
his vital signs were found to be normal
and he felt
better the source adds that kanye is now
back in the studio working on
music the rapper was supposed to drop
his new album donda
on july 24th but it's nowhere to be
found
and yay has yet to update his fans on it
i mean like that's not stuff we put on
social media i'm not gonna you know
just start tweeting what my thoughts are
but yeah we have those moments
this comes just moments after he
publicly apologized to his wife kim
kardashian west on twitter
during his presidential rally in south
carolina kanye delivered an emotional
speech
in which he said he and kim discussed
the idea of aborting their first child
north even if my wife were to divorce me
after this speech she brought north
into the world even when i didn't want
to
then later claimed on twitter that kim
and her mother kris
jenner were trying to get a doctor to
lock him up
he might say things that might get
misinterpreted
and people don't see the context behind
it but i always know his heart
yay asked for forgiveness from kim
writing
i would like to apologize to my wife kim
for going public with something that was
a private matter
i did not cover her like she has covered
me
to kim i want to say i know i hurt you
please forgive me
thank you for always being there for me
we have different views sometimes we
have different
things but that's my husband you know a
source told et
that kim and the family are happy to see
kanye apologize
but at the end of the day the most
important thing for them is kanye
getting the help he needs
kanye said hurtful things to kim and the
family and in time that will heal
but kanye's health is priority the
source adds
since kanye hasn't been responsive to
kim and her family's attempt to help him
they are hoping this public olive branch
is a start for him
in allowing kim to help at the end of
the day
life is about being happy being who you
are
and i feel like we are so blessed to
have the best support system and the
best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through